there's much more to the question of
migration than urgent support for syrian
refugees quotas for legal migration or
controlling the mediterranean
according to a new resolution in the
european parliament it's also about
finding an holistic approach to
immigration and asylum we asked the
president of the civil liberties
committee claude mores what he means and
how to relaunch the debate in europe
let's start with the first question
coming from mr ambrosi from the
international organization for migration
president juncker has called for more
adequate measure to enable legal
migration and curb the irregular
movement and the fatalities that come
with it you have called the eu
to take concrete steps in this direction
how does your resolution address this
question okay so what do you answer well
the resolution is a holistic approach to
migration and this is what i tried to
say
in the resolution that
we have to take the tough choices on
migration so more legal routes means
that the member states need to really
wake up to what that means what that
means is we need a policy on managed
migration it means that if the european
union despite the tough austerity that
we are going through we have to
understand and admit that we need
migration that we accept migration who
is doing all of these low-wage jobs all
over europe so if you sort of wake up
call these resolutions to say
governments and the new commission now
we have to speak seriously about
migration we have to admit that there is
a need for migration that migration is
happening there is still an aging
population in the european union for
there is low wage migration there is
high skilled migration coming from
beyond the european union there is a
provocative question now uh coming from
united kingdom
europe has higher consumption levels
than most of the rest of the world
isn't the case that stabilizing and then
reducing our population would help us
reduce carbon emissions protect the
environment and conserve natural
resources what do you think about this
kind of
of current positions in the united
kingdom i don't accept that
the issue of migration is only linked to
the issue of population there are many
other factors to population and
migration is a global issue there are
costs to migration in western european
countries as has been expressed here
but
those costs also have benefits migration
brings economic benefit too we know this
economically it has been proven that
there is an economic benefit to
migration
migrants pay their taxes they are more
likely to be economically active more
likely to claim less benefits than the
host community we know this is a fact
in the resolution you say they should
ask yourself and legal access to the new
asylum system
okay this hasn't been done during all
the syrian
crisis so my question is are you
confident then
this approach to asylum seeker could
change in the next future
the european union policy towards
issues like syria is that we have a
resettlement policy
the other policies towards
issues like the syrian problem are
really from member states
so the resettlement program is not
working well you have a very
disproportionate issue in in
resettlement you have some countries
taking virtually no syrian refugees and
some taking a lot so the burden sharing
element is not happening which is why
our resolution is pointing towards this
holistic approach we need better
burden-sharing we need the council the
member states to do their job the
commission is asking for it the
parliament is asking for it but the
member states are not doing their job
they're not burden-sharing but do we
need the other changes
for that you don't need to change much
the dublin convention exists it can be
reformed you have the directives
on reception conditions
you have the dublin and you have the um
common european asylum system in place
all of that is fine the issue is
implementation it's not being
implemented by the member states so now
we go back to immigration frontex and we
have a question coming from the
mediterranean human rights network
administration
cooperation
the big problem with frontex right now
is that it's a very small operation it's
an operation of the european union but
it spots
a people who are literally drowning or
at danger in the mediterranean at a very
important time but frontex is inadequate
we need more funding for frontex because
it's trying to fill the gaps
left by the lack of action by member
states boys thank you very much